it's too much pressure that's my problem
i can't
i can't handle pressure sometimes
pressure makes me talk different
i'm serious you ever have like that
social pressure talk to somebody who's
fake
and they make you fake like that comedy
like hey how you doing you're like fine
how are you
like i don't even talk like that
[Applause]
i get sick of that [ __ ]
trump don't give [ __ ] trump made his own
rules
trump was on the news they asked trump
about
leaks trump said the leaks are real
but the news is fake
[Applause]
i heard about the leaks on the news sir
you are confusing me
that's like the police pull you over you
tell them the blunt ain't real
but the smoke is take your ass to real
jail damn since you're
i don't know i feel like we we need to
start not being so angry
at things i i sit on the internet
sometimes and i'm just like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that [ __ ] that [ __ ] that
i can't even
and with people instagram i mean i can't
really go on
every morning i check instagram and i
wake up with that
with resentment jealousy yeah but that's
all
you got to take yeah it's really
unhealthy it is i do that i do that a
lot too
i definitely think that i'm trying to
put my phone down way more
just because it's jealous of me in this
book i read oh wait go ahead go ahead
yeah i get i mean i get i don't get
jealous of other djs but i think it's
just like that
you just start things start pissing you
off you read people's captions like [ __ ]
you dude
yeah yeah yeah you mean that [ __ ] yeah
you [ __ ]
yeah yeah people try to get real
philosophical and you know who they are
absolutely like dude your caption
doesn't match who you are man that's
another thing it's like you know
somebody right i know some comedians
well and then they try to put out this
thing that they're nice or they're
adventurous
or that you know i mean they they're
interesting right and i'm like
no you're a dull piece of [ __ ]
and put that out there because you don't
do that you're on a mountain
who brought you there you didn't bring
yourself there you have some [ __ ]
girl woman i'm just looking right rent
it ranting yeah yeah yeah
i'm ranting okay thank you hollywood
racism has been solved this week in
activism no one asked for entertainers
continued their relentless fight to stay
relevant i mean make change
the dixie chicks also known as migos for
midwest moms
are now just the chicks smart move
making a comeback by chopping off your
dixie
snl removed an episode where humans soft
serve jimmy fallon
did something funny not the blackface he
pretended to be a comedian
nbc you're worried we're going to watch
an episode of snl from 20 years ago
we didn't watch the one from saturday
and they took down an episode of golden
girls for mud masks
black people don't need protection from
blanche they need protection from
becky entertainers aren't the only good
looking people with zero talent making
change
house wise with kids at college or as
some of you refer to them
realtors have stopped using the term
master bedroom
really that's not even the most racist
term in real estate you can still buy
plantation style houses and people still
do it
no jew is sending their kid to a
concentration style camp it's just crazy
for the last month black people with a
capital b have been very clear about the
change they want
they don't want to get killed by the
cops and if they are they want the cops
prosecuted and
woke ally hollywood listened to that
information
digested it and responded with give them
the cartoons nailed it
fox put out a statement saying the
simpsons will no longer have white
actors voice non-white characters
obviously
that doesn't apply to fox news jenny
slate unknown for her work on snl quit
her role as a half black half jewish
girl
in a cartoon about horny children this
second child-related piece by john
mullaney even though he doesn't have any
kids of his own
it's getting weird john also nick crowe
looks like a platypus running for mayor
anyway in her animation proclamation
jenny stated
it was an example of white privilege and
white supremacy and she was engaging in
an
act of erasure of black people jenny
turn on the news sweetheart
cartoons aren't the ones erasing black
people also you're 100
jewish a black person is 100 black
so neither of you are 100 missy let's be
honest
where the [ __ ] are we gonna find a
hormonal half black
half jew all right good point but no you
need a mixed
race woman if only they could find maya
rudolph but she was probably too busy
voicing other characters
on the [ __ ] show how oblivious are
you guys but at least they took action
while the show was still on the air
bojack horseman actor allison brie said
she regrets playing a vietnamese woman
on the show first of all
no one asked second of all people want
representation not regret the show is
over
but you still found a way to make it
about yourself and get some pc points
i mean how close does an actor have to
be in order to play the character
bojack was voiced by will arnett not an
actual horse man
also how important do these [ __ ]
voice actors think they are
i mean it's absurd you're anonymous i
can't name the people that voiced ariel
aladdin spongebob nemo
as a kid every saturday i watch x-men
not that x-men
i can't name a single voice actor from
that show
no one knows voice actors we don't know
who played miguel
moana wally and if it was stephen
hawking i don't want to hear him
apologize just shut up and dribble
i didn't know a black guy played samurai
jack or shredder to me
those characters were asian ideally
these actors reflect the characters they
play
[ __ ] it let children play children in
melanie's next cartoon just be careful
who casts it but sometimes
it's difficult i mean to dub every anime
you would need to find a japanese actor
who speaks [ __ ] swahili
sometimes you just need the best person
for the role that's what jada did but
you know what's also important
that the writers who tell the story and
the animators who depict them
share the character's life experiences
getting rid of voice actors doesn't fix
the problem it's just pruning the tree
but never addressing the roots of the
power imbalance as stupid and
sanctimonious as these actors sound
at least they're trying to help yes they
made the money first yes the timing is
curious as the canceled culture mob sets
its sights on hollywood but still
they're sacrificing money and fame to
help people with less representation
maybe they were seduced by the
opportunity and now they're trying to
atone for it only they know for certain
that being said the style of these
announcements is
so [ __ ] annoying how many non-binary
baristas does it take to craft an
apology
i swear every time it's like liberal
buzzword bingo toxic
erasure playing a cartoon character that
you half represent
isn't white supremacy thinking you can
erase
black people because of it is you're
exaggerating the severity of the
situation to get hollywood belly rubs
it's this white saviorism i [ __ ] hate
minorities
aren't fragile little children that need
to be coddled that's celebrities
if you want to step down great just keep
it moving because no one asked for this
and no protest did someone have a sign
that said defund the golden girls or
abolish the master bedroom
so here's what we're going to do
realtors you want to make things better
for black people
start showing them the houses they
qualify for hollywood you want to make
things more equitable
hire more black writers and actually
promote them all this nonsense is just
paranoid performative [ __ ] and we
can see right through it and dixie
chicks i'm sorry
the chicks keep making those hits thanks
peace
you know those people you say hello and
they don't say hello back they just
smile
and it's a fake smile i know i've talked
about this in my podcast there was
somebody when i lived in new york used
to do that
and i fell for it like the first 67
times i'd be walking down the hall
and this lady would be walking the other
way
with her [ __ ] kids and i always just
be i'd be like hey good morning or hey
after
you know hello or good afternoon
whatever the [ __ ] you say right big
[ __ ] wave hey
fellow human being being polite how are
you
right and she would always do the same
thing she tilt her head to the side like
she was going oh
and then she'd do this smile which she
she wouldn't show any teeth just
like the jay leno smile and then her
eyes would would like squint up like she
was looking into the sun
big stupid red lipstick and every
[ __ ] time i was just like oh what if
i just [ __ ] punched her right in the
face
made her kids cry and i just laughed i
didn't laugh i just walked away
you know i'd still be affected there'd
be a part of my soul that i lost when i
did it
but i'll tell you in that moment
and that catcher right as she closes her
eyes
you know like a [ __ ] old samuelson
move don't even drop the glove keep it
on
and just blast her right in the face and
i wanted to do that
every [ __ ] time and then finally one
day she walked towards me
and i was walking towards her and uh
she actually started to anticipate me
saying hello
because we're looking right at each
other and i'm in my head
just going i'm not saying anything i'm
saying hello to this [ __ ] says hello to
me
this is another thing that makes you die
early you know
is [ __ ] literally sitting in your
apartment your little ass
shoe box of apartment in new york
plotting
scheming conspiring ah you're gonna
[ __ ]
not say hello to this [ __ ] the next
time you see her you know
as you're eating a bacon egg and cheese
and adding an extra couple of miles for
you had to beat every couple of times
right so anyway she comes walking at me
i'm walking her i'm like i'm not [ __ ]
saying hello this time you know
and we got right to the point where it's
like who's gonna blink and i timed it
perfectly
she anticipated me saying hello and she
started to tilt her head
and i [ __ ] did my impression of what
she did
and i of course did it completely over
the top like i literally laid my head on
my shoulders squinted my eyes
and i made this ridiculous face and
continued to walk
and she never looked at me in the hall
again
and this is the genius of it she just
it's not like she knows what the [ __ ]
she looks like
i'm so self-involved i assume she
totally understood my point what i was
trying to make
you know like say hello stop making that
stupid face
she probably looked at like what the
[ __ ] is with that guy he has some sort
of mental tick
i don't want him around my children
but you know what it made me feel better